welcome back to cbs this morning only on
cbs this morning we are hearing from
three men who were just released from
prison after spending
24 years behind bars for a crime they
say they did not commit
george bell gary johnson and rohan bolt
were each sentenced to at least
50 years for a deadly attempted robbery
in new york city
but on friday they were able to reunite
with their families
after a judge overturned their
convictions their attorneys argued the
case was based on false confessions
and racial bias nikki batiste spoke with
the three men
the feeling of freedom is so surreal
right now like
words just can't describe it it's a
feeling that comes after more than two
decades in prison for 44 year old george
bell
46 year old gary johnson and 59 year old
rohan bolt
front door of the crime scene their
story starts on december 21
1996 when two men were shot and killed
during an attempted robbery in queens
one an off-duty new york police officer
just days later
bell johnson and bolt were arrested bell
and johnson claimed they were forced to
confess
after hours-long interrogations
confessions
they later recanted how can you explain
to viewers that you
confessed to a murderer you say you
didn't commit
actually they took advantage of my
mental state that tactic was just to
keep me up
until i was just that mentally fatigued
that i was perplexed
how are you treated by investigators
harsh both mentally and physically
when you say physically what do you mean
grab me
choking me they're just very aggressive
when i put my head down to get some kind
of rest to collect my thoughts
they'll come in and just bang on the
table how are you feeling
scared confused
and angry attorneys rita dave and mark
wolinski
represent the three men i think that a
lot of people will say well
if i didn't do it why would i say i did
it but you can say that in the comfort
of your living room
not when you're in a little room with
four police officers talking to you
and you can't speak to your parents do
you think race played a role in this
case absolutely of course um a 19 year
old black kid
he must be guilty he confessed he must
be guilty
are you innocent yes sir i am
but that innocence was still in doubt
until 2019
when this police report resurfaced in
another wrongful conviction case
this time unredacted and with crucial
details
a never before seen third page held key
evidence
that implicates a local gang in the 1996
shooting
not bell johnson and bolt just say that
there's never mistakes
it's arrogant to think that there isn't
that's why melinda katz created
a wrongful conviction unit when she
became the queens county district
attorney just 14 months ago
in this case do you think it was a
mistake or do you think there was some
prosecutorial
misconduct my conviction integrity unit
that spent 11 months on this case
truly believes that it was not a
purposeful misconduct
katz's office joined the motion to
vacate the convictions of bell johnson
and bolt
because prosecutors withheld evidence
that if disclosed
could have possibly affected the outcome
of the case
june 4th rors all three defendants
that led to a judge approving the
release of the three men
last week when they released me the
first thing i did was look for my wife
when i found her i hugged her so i had
to apologize afterwards
how has 24 years in prison changed you
i'm still
trying to regroup right now because
24 years of my life spending somewhere
where i don't belong
i try to do the best and basically i
just go day to day
you know i still can't sleep me neither
i open up the fridge at night just to
open it up
how are you feeling i wake up with a
smile every day
i wake up knowing there's a burden
lifted over my shoulders and it's a
beautiful feeling and i know that
it's going to get greater every day
just yesterday one of the original
prosecutors of this case
resigned from his role at another
district attorney's office
current prosecutors in queens will
decide over the next three months
whether or not to retry the three men as
of now the men
still face their original charges
anthony
batiste thank you nikki wow i open up
the frigid night just to open up the
fridge
mr bell johnson and bolt just imagine
you can't get back 24 years of your life
no will there be any compensation for
these men i think the attorney said it
best
why would you confess to something you
didn't do it's easy to say in the
comfort of your living room that's right
but when you're being physically abused
emotionally abused and you're not so
many have examples of it now
yes many of them are men of color that
it keeps
happening over and over and over again
confused to hear that it was a mistake
that they went to jail for so long not
misconduct describe it that way again
exactly